yeah well equity
uh is another it's a synonym for
the sort of the obverse which is racism
and white supremacy i've been hearing
more my ears more attuned to biden's
endless repetition of systemic racism
and uh they're the same thing
i mean equity is the response to
systemic racism equity means
uh quotas it means the destruction of
meritocratic standards it means
you hire and promote on the basis of
race not on the basis of qualifications
and any institution which does not show
a proportional number
uh of of blacks or hispanics
is thereby by definition uh
systemically racist and engaged in bias
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
fellow at the manhattan institute a
contributing editor
at city journal and author of the
diversity delusion
heather mcdonald welcome back to the
reuben report it's great
sort of being with you dave as close as
we can be as close as we can be at the
moment but that's a good place to start
because you are a new york city girl but
you have fled
new york city to go to california
during a lockdown what's going on over
there heather
who would believe it but actually new
york is is
more insane at least than orange county
i'm in irvine
and here at least i can swim which is
very important to my
my mental health my overall health new
york city
uh is in a state of utter hysteria
my pool makes it virtually impossible to
swim
so here it feels a little saner
without restaurants in new york without
the opera there's really no point being
there and of course
uh it is turning into a situation of
maximal squalor
crime threat uh people getting assaulted
on the streets so
i don't know when i'm gonna go back
frankly i bought a one-way ticket out
here
and uh still waiting for any any reason
to go back and i don't think yeah
well there you go for the people that
would say who in their right mind would
go to california in the midst of all of
this we found one person and she's
coming from new york so that that kind
of says it all
look everything that that i've talked to
you about over the last couple years
you've been on the show a few times
it seems that everything that you've
been writing about that you've been
studying all of these things they seem
to all be kind of coming to fruition
right now so so we're gonna we're gonna
try to hit on a whole bunch of stuff but
i guess first
since you fled new york to come to cali
are you surprised in any way
that these big government progressive
lefty policies are ruining these cities
and states
no but what i have been surprised by is
how perfectly the response to
this pandemic mirrors political
uh pre-existing categories it's it's
very
curious that there is something truly
fundamental constitutional in the way
people
view the world that there should be so
clear a distinction between red state
individuals who
by and large are locked down skeptics
and then in the blue states the
willingness
of vast majorities of the population to
put up with rules that are
utterly arbitrary i mean they're made up
out of whole cloth
the distinctions about when you can go
out how many people you can have at a
table
it's ridiculous and yet the passivity of
the population before this
is completely remarkable so it it seems
like
there is in fact something
very profound in the way
people's psyches are constructed with
regards to their
attitudes of either credulity or
skepticism
towards the assertion of elite power
and i i am very grateful to you dave for
giving me the opportunity to say i
told you
and you have too those of us have been
warning about the
the the the landslide
of poison that's been coming out of the
university for decades
and people kind of turn their eyes away
and they say oh haha it's so funny these
snowflakes
it's not funny guys uh the whole safety
is an epic
that is a feminist a feminine uh
ideology of victimhood and the
the aversion to risk and
entrepreneurship
that we see on universities now with
this whole
wellness initiatives and and and you
know people needing safe spaces
that is covet writ large it's the safety
is a method
against the spirit of entrepreneurship
and risk
you're giving me so much to work with
there so so as someone that loves
numbers because you're always diving
into the
actual numbers of what's going on in our
inner cities what's happening at
at the places of at this point
quote-unquote higher ed et cetera et
cetera
was there any point when the lockdown
started roughly a year ago at this point
11 months ago at this point was there
any point where you saw
numbers that made sense to do all of the
things that we've done
so you know that first two weeks i was
on the show saying let's do
the two-week lockdown because every
expert said two weeks to flatten the
curve
i said i'm not an expert in this but i'm
gonna bring on some experts to talk
about it
but i was worried from from beat one
about the never-ending extension
of all of this did you ever see numbers
that were like oh okay this is what we
have to do right now
well dave i don't want to like toot my
own horn here but i have to say i was
first out of the gate among
conservatives
and locked down skepticism with a piece
in the new criterion that was compared
to what
and it was putting what were then the
numbers
uh in context of other types of of
deaths that we put up with i mean 40
000 highway deaths a year that we could
eliminate entirely
by uh reducing highway speeds to 20
miles an hour
we don't because we are willing to say
there will be 40 000 lives
lost we are we value our efficiency
and our convenience more uh and i i have
to say
the distinction i drew earlier between
liberal and conservative views
wasn't completely accurate because i was
randomly attacked by many conservative
writers
for being willing to kill off grandma
but no we saw
in march uh the italian health agency
published data on the
characteristics of coronavirus
descendants
nothing has changed since march 2020
average age 80 almost three
comorbidities
being obesity diabetes heart disease and
then others like cancer
nothing has changed we knew almost from
the start
that this was a disease that targeted
the very elderly
even neil ferguson the author
of that infamous uh study that was
predicting
20 million dead in the united states
uh if we did nothing
even he admitted that two-thirds of the
people
who would die in 2020 from coronavirus
would have died anyway from other causes
now is it is it happy that they die of
course not but to be honest
death is the inevitable
banal mediocre end of all life
and when you get to be a certain age you
know the new york times has this
modeling
section that they run periodically
called those we've lost
and they list like a 101 year old
vet of four wars and he's supposed to be
a coronavirus victim
as if he's going to live for another 20
years without coronavirus
they do this regularly yeah we we had a
hundred years no
it was 101 year old maybe 100
uh last of the tuskegee airmen again
he's going to die of pneumonia and he's
probably dying with
not from coving which is the other big
sleight of hand that our public health
experts use to try and inflate the death
numbers
were you shocked when you got some of
that pushback from conservatives i
remember there was a specific day
very early on maybe around april where
ben shapiro was on my show and he said
what we all know to be true
which is that you're going to have to
live with some amount of risk as you
just said and a certain amount of people
we just accept they die as part of the
circle of life
you don't want it to happen you mitigate
the risks but this is what actuaries do
uh but i saw a ton of pushback from
conservatives and it was like wait
when did since when do conservatives
believe in a perfectly safe system
i agree and again so i have to comp
complicate my initial black and white
sort of manichaean distinction
it is absolutely the case that a whole
lot of
conservative intellectuals took the
uh ridiculous attitude that was
expressed by governor andrew cuomo
initially that
if we can save just one life there's no
amount of lockdowns which will not be
worth it
well that is absurd uh you know if that
had been the attitude there would be no
united states today
uh there would have been nobody who took
off from plymouth rock because
the chance of survival in the
transatlantic voyage back then was about
one in six
and so it should be the hallmark of
not just conservatives but of human
rational human beings
to realize that you make trade-offs and
that you balance one sort of risk
against the other but yes i was very
surprised
uh that conservatives had adopted this
safetyism ethic
which is to focus on one particular type
of risk
uh to the exclusion of any other type of
consideration and
you know again it gets worrisome because
all these arguments have been out there
the argument that i've made and others
have made you've made which is that
but what about deaths from suicide from
untreated
uh illnesses and people because people
are too scared out of their minds to go
to a hospital
what about the destruction of children
across the globe from the poverty from
the lack of education
we are we are consigning them to
lives of stunted capacity all of those
trade-offs are not being made
uh so it it's sort of the core of
conservatives which isn't to say that
there aren't a whole lot
that were just as spooked as as the
liberals with their
math wearing their masks at 5 00 a.m in
central park
when their six people spread over 800
acres
so you're not going to put on a mask for
the rest of this interview
i i'm going to get my virtue from other
means fair enough fair enough
what do you think if you had to grade
the professional
class at this point if you had to grade
the experts because i think
actually the next coming crisis that
we're going to have when we you know now
we just go from crisis to crisis or at
least
you know two crises to another two or
whatever it is is that i think
that a huge amount of our experts have
completely lost all credibility when you
see videos of fouchy saying masks don't
do anything
then wear a mask now two masks maybe
kinda
and then you know biden another 100 days
federal mask mandate why should the
people in montana be living under the
same rules as someone in metropolitan
new york city
just sort of the elite class do you
think that they've sort of done
irreparable damage to themselves
no i don't know well
from an objective point of view yes but
but
what one has learned uh over this last
two years or so and we knew that
beforehand
is how profoundly
powerful one's pre-existing conceptions
are
and world view so i don't think fauci is
at all discredited
in that very large portion of the
population that views the new york times
as
as gospel truth and you know i
you're an optimist and you think that
most people are
are uh skeptical of of the
liberal worldview and ideology
i'm not so sure about that and right now
certainly
the liberal elites are in the seat of
power
and you know the vote for biden as far
as i was concerned
was sadly a vote for safetyism
it was a vote for uh turning
america's back on its history of of
entrepreneurship and risk-taking and
rationality
and a sane attitude towards uh
what life is about you know trump got a
lot of voids but
biden got more and and so i i don't know
i
i think that the whole world is as
andrew sullivan said we're all on campus
now
and um this this
ideology is very powerful the more
people who graduate from college
the harder it's going to be to turn
things around and yet there were plenty
of people we've talked about it before
telling
telling you and i i mean i remember when
when we did an event i think at berkeley
together
saying oh you guys are making this up
this is it'll just stay on college
campuses and then what do they always
say
then they'll go out to the real world
well apparently the real world
didn't have uh many safeties equipped
well the big lie on college campuses for
decades has been that
the characteristic that defines america
above all else
is racism uh and and
so you have this cultivation of a victim
mentality
where to be a female on a college campus
is to be at risk of one's life
whereas in fact there's nothing more
privileged than being
an american female anywhere but on an
ameri on a college campus are you
kidding me i mean the whole place is run
by females to its utter
uh you know destruction or to be a
under urm as the as the jargon goes and
i hear today that somehow
uh acronyms are now racist i didn't get
the explanation but i'm not surprised
because everything is racist but to be a
urm which is an underrepresented
minority it's also to be at risk of
one's life
notwithstanding the fact that every
single college
with any kind of selectivity ties itself
into knots to admit as many blacks and
hispanics as possible
with test scores that would be
automatically disqualifying if they were
presented by whites and asians
so this idea that racism is and sexism
are the things we should be thinking
about most and that define
everything and are the reason to tear
down western civilization
that now is the driving force
in the in the world at large in the
united
that the states to what you just said
will actually
start a new type of racism when the
average
white kid or asian and you've written a
bunch about this
when the average asian kid is going to
have to consistently score
quite literally sometimes 20 percentage
points higher
than the average black or latino kid you
could see why someone would become
racist not not you should not become
racist but
the system will have reorganized things
in a way that will
that will breed resentment absolutely
and uh it's only a matter of logic
all you have to ask is well why does
every other group get identity politics
and not whites i'm you know whatever you
view of that statement as a logical
matter now i guess they have the whole
argument about
well blacks can't be racist because they
then define racism to be
something accompanied with by power but
if you're a working class white
uh you don't really feel like you've got
a whole lot of white
privilege but you know right now there's
a professor
uh in florida who is
under enormous pressure he may have been
fired
for talking about black privilege and
frankly he's absolutely right again if
you're
if you're applying to google right now
and you're a black engineer
you've got it made you you know you can
just write your ticket you can ask for
your salary
same if you're applying to be a black
chemistry professor
at berkeley or caltech or harvard
uh they've the the welcome mat is
open for you bra black privilege is real
and so
it is quite logical for whites to say or
asians to say but asians are
kind of allowed ethnic identity but
if if they can somehow claim to be
oppressed as well and there's a
it's very weird what goes on with asian
identity where they kind of want to be
students of color and then the
administration says no no you can't be
students of color because you're too
academically successful but
you see this at uc berkeley where they
want the victim status
but yeah it's maybe it will happen it's
it's a
question of sort of the trump
deplorables versus
the elite whites and how much they can
suppress that but
it is arguably bubbling along under the
surface
i fear that i know your answer here but
are you surprised at all to now see that
not only
has this basically decimated the
universities but we're seeing this now
every
well basically in every blue city where
now all of
even the private schools are being
infected with all of this
that every the charter schools of course
the public schools but basically schools
that were the elite schools of new york
city
are now instead of having um
you know score based admissions
we have equity-based emissions they're
going to destroy their own schools
this has been going on for a long time
and you know sort of the
one of the rules of media is you have to
pretend like
something you're saying is for the first
time i mean i wrote an article
years ago decades ago about elite prep
schools like andover and exeter and
in new england uh that were already back
in the 90s
embracing multiculturalism and and
telling their black students that they
must think of themselves as oppressed
and
putting chips on the shoulder of
everybody minority student
but it it certainly is getting worse and
what i've
been researching for a while now and
keep getting distracted by other things
but which breaks my heart
to pieces uh is the assault right now
on the thing i love most in life which
is classical music
and what i've been noticing is that
there's not a single
guardian of our great traditions of art
whether it's a museum director
or in case of music an orchestra
conductor uh orchestra manager
a superstar singer or soloist
certainly not the classical music press
which is
willing who is willing to defend this
tradition of such sublime
expression of of extraordinary
variety of human experience
and and uh communication
from the charge that it is defined by
racism
and white patriarchal power it is
ludicrous there's a madman
at hunter college which is one of the
city university of new york colleges in
new york city
a music theorist who's involved in a
very big spout right now
over a viennese music theorist known as
called heinrich schenker
and this this hunter music theorist
phillip ewell
is mad he he defines everything in
classical music
as a function of white maleness so he he
says well beethoven
you know he's a he's an okay composer
but the only reason we think of him as
great is because he's white
and male this is insane this is insane
but it's happening everywhere everything
is being torn down
and the people who have been given the
privilege
of defending and passing on this
inheritance
are cowards and they have all
rolled over and played dead and said of
course
ours our inheritance is racist and we
are now from here on in
going to make decisions based on the
trivialities
of gonads and melanin
um i i'm guessing that gonads and
melanin that could be the title of your
next book first off that was
go nuts and melanin um do you get a lot
of
academics reaching out to you telling
you their their version
of this story and do they ever do
anything i mean what percentage do you
think actually
speak up my inbox is is almost like a
therapy session from these people at
this point
yeah they're terrified uh there's you
know i just find it amazing that the
left claims that
oh cancel culture you guys are just
victim whiners it doesn't exist
what are you talking about again we are
there's a perceptual divide here that is
so massive and i
despair how you bridge it but the left
really does not think
that they're censoring people but yes
practically every single faculty member
and
every conservative student is walking
around
scared to death that he's going to be
the next one
to fall under and what really worries me
and dave you know you are our
premier exponent of free speech
conservative
newspapers student newspapers are so
essential
i was not a conservative as a college
student so this was
and i don't even know back in the 70s if
there was a conservative newspaper at
yale i think probably not it was a much
less political
time but they are essential
well what's been going on recently with
uh in the uh now that sort of seems like
ancient history during the trump era he
would nominate judges to the federal
bench
and their enemies would dig up writings
of these students from their college
time there was a guy that went to
stanford
uh who was nominated for the ninth
circuit and he wrote some very
scathing and satirical pieces about
multiculturalism
well he was denied the the going forward
with the nomination
not just by the democrats but by marco
rubio
and and tim scott to their eternal
discredit
naomi rao did squeak through but she was
critical
of uh campus rape culture and she had to
backtrack
and and confess her sins and say oh well
of course there's rape culture
when there is not uh but what i'm
worried about
is any any student
who is forward oriented and future
oriented
will say i don't dare write the truth
about what's going on on a college
campus today
because that's going to be used against
me uh
in my next job and so you've got a very
subtle self-censorship that's going on
that means that the truth is going to
get
harder and harder to get you know i'm
reminded of an event that i did at
university of new hampshire a couple
years ago that went viral where there
was a whole bunch of protesters and kids
were screaming at me and this one girl
a brown-skinned girl she happened to be
brown skinned doesn't matter to me
but i'm mentioning it because it gives
context to the story she started
screaming at me heckling and saying that
i could be
killed when i walk out of here and i
thought
wait it's the middle of the day in new
hampshire
are students being killed but i realized
what she was saying
was so emotionally disconnected from
reality
that there was virtually nothing that i
could say to her and it became very
clear that there was nothing i could say
to her to calm down
but that they had they had ginned up
such an irrational fear in her
that it had almost in essence taken over
every other
faculty that she has and these are the
universities that are supposedly that
still
present themselves to these idiotic
donors who keep
funneling truckloads of cash into their
maw
to be used for more hate and and
and uh victimology and destruction of
our traditions
these are the colleges that are teaching
them this fantastical
delusion that they are at risk and it is
what is now in our culture at large
whether it's the idea that
children shouldn't be in school because
of covid or again
people you know i'm here in orange
county and it's
better my pool rules here are better
than new york but otherwise
i walk in the faculty housing area of of
university of california irvine
at as early as i can get out there to
avoid the damn faculty members
who you know at six am again they're
you're out in this huge
fresh air they're wearing masks are you
people
insane but that that one feels alive and
being frightened
and we also see this now with this i
would argue completely fantastical
narrative
that the world is under threat from
white supremacist violence
uh and and pouring troops they keep
coming into the capital
you know they're coming into every other
capital uh
in this sort of deliberate theater
supporting the lie that the country's
biggest threat right now
is these kooks uh that that got out of
control
and were horribly ill-mannered and
disgusting in the capital but that was a
one-off
and it is not the the character of our
our
our country right now but that is
another sort of
uh safetyism lie that is now
a typical product of the academy so i
wanna i wanna dive into that because i
know you have a bunch to talk about
there but
just before we do that i think it'll
segue sort of nicely is you've mentioned
multiculturalism a few times and i think
when the average person hears the phrase
multiculturalism they think yes we
should be a multicultural
society isn't that what we are my
neighbors from this country my bro
you know my aunt is from that country
blah blah aren't we multicultural
but there's a distinct difference
between multiculturalism and the way
that america has done
the melting pot is that a fair statement
and can you explain it a little bit
because i think people once they hear
you say i'm against multiculturalism
they automatically think that that has
some racist beginning to it
you know well the reality the empirical
fact of multiculturalism is it is
not inclusive it's not additive it is
subtractive
it is done in the name of
labeling the western tradition which has
been encyclopedic it has been inclusive
it has taken
in people from across the globe to to
put that to denigrate it and to teach
students and adults to see it through
the lens of oppression which is
just tragic utterly tragic
uh and and the multicultural idea
is one that is antithetical to the power
of the human imagination
i don't know if there's a single more
idiotic conception than the one
of cultural appropriation that is trying
to
draw boundaries around the human
imagination
and say that if you're say a a white
female writer
you cannot write a novel that has a
black male protagonist in it because
that would be
culturally appropriate are you kidding
me
the you know there's the greatest artist
of our time
have seen into people very different
than themselves
i've seen some of the most extraordinary
explorations of female sexual jealousy
by male writers uh who simply possess
the the feature of empathy so
multiculturalism
as practiced and as given within our
world today
is not saying let's yes let's learn
the uh great epic traditions of
india or china but rather
it means that heihei ho ho western civ
has got to go
which is the jesse jackson infamous
chant from stanford of the 80s that's
that's the reality of it and the other
reality is
frankly uh as as
as inclusive it has been it is
a european tradition and
it is white sorry mostly not exclusively
but there weren't a whole lot of blacks
writing
renaissance madrigals so if you're an
early music group
you know doing baroque music
and you've now decided that your mission
is social justice and your mission is to
be an anti-racism organization
which music organization after music
organization is declaring itself
our mission is to be anti-racist sorry
just the reality of history is
there not a lot of black composers the
reason there's not black composers is
not because of racism
it's because that's what the
demographics were nobody goes to
african music and says well we can't
perform it because
there's no whites or or we can't do
balinese you know the monkey chant
because
there were no british whites in there
there are certain
realities of history and and population
groups
that that's just what history is you
cannot change it
all right so let's let's shift to where
you were going there about the capitol
hill protest are you telling me heather
mcdonald
that that man with the horns and the
face paint
that that guy was not the leader of a
giant coup they weren't going to take
over the entire government that day
because if you watch cnn jake tapper
there was an insurrection these people
were going to take over all of our
governmental institutions
well i am not going to defend them for
an instant and i
i cannot state enough uh that
as a a prerequisite probably dominant
everything i'm saying i'm
not justifying them i'm not making an
apology for them
but this was a one-off you know this was
the moment
that the left has been hoping for that
we were told
uh you know was going to happen after
the election it never
happened uh and these guys got out of
control
it is also true uh that as we heard with
the black lives matter protests you know
we heard
for the riots the race riots that did
a hundred thousand times more
damage than happened as a physical
matter
and as a life matter than happened on
january six
the rolling riots that we saw over the
summer
through the fall that are now being
completely
rewritten out of history by the
mainstream media not that they
acknowledged them
at all at the time but now they're being
completely erased those were
far more destructive in terms of
property damage and
damage to government property than
anything that happened on january 6.
i simply do not believe that what
happened then
represents an ongoing terror threat
these people are disorganized they're
losers they got out of control and
they have been in the grips of what i
would say
uh is a delusion which is the idea that
the
election was systematically rigged
uh you know i but what i you know
one's attitude towards what went on on
january 6 to a certain extent
will be influenced by whether you
believe the rigging narrative
they believe it and and if the election
was systemically rigged
that is very serious business that
undermines the legitimacy
of our government and justifies
something it doesn't justify violence
but it justifies something
uh and and so that that makes this whole
uh debate about what went on
complicated because there's a factual
dispute at the heart of of both sides
from a legal perspective um do you think
trump was inciting them when he was
saying i mean he did repeatedly say
peaceful but it's
but i think what a lot of people are
saying is well what did he think was
going to happen when when they got there
i mean actually i think had things not
gotten out of hand ted cruz would have
issued a you know a statement that day
saying you know i object to this or that
and rand paul would have done the same
the day would have finished up and then
and then actually what i think what
happened was people would have realized
it was over i think that's where it was
all heading
yeah i'm not an expert on the law of
incitement so
i'm not i don't know what the legal
standards are but
it's complicated i mean he's he's got
statements and again
this is what's difficult is how you view
what he said does depend
on what your view is of the underlying
claim of rigging
you can't get around that if you think
the rigging idea was
preposterous as i do then
you know for him to go and say you know
take back the capital
uh sounds possibly
too provocative but if it's right if if
he really was the rightful
winner and the election was stolen from
him
uh then his rhetoric
looks simply factual you know i want to
stop you there for a second because it's
interesting because even though you're
really just talking about sort of the
sort of psychological makeup of some of
the people and the behaviors related to
the information that we all get
i know it's very possible that youtube
is going to take this video down because
we're really not even supposed to talk
about this even though
you're fully saying that you believe
that it that the election was
legitimate but that's just the sort of
information war that we're in related to
all of this
you know the question dave is
what is this country going to look like
in five years or three years
this this censorship is happening so
quickly
i mean my mind is just blown by it i
don't know
what one can do and and the other thing
that worries me
and this comes out of the academy again
up to now
federal judges have been pretty good in
striking down
free speech limitations on college
campuses which
you know they they the things that get
appealed to them tend to be the
speech codes which are by now are sort
of archaic and
a trivial problem compared to the much
broader
campus climate of censorship but the
judges have been pretty good on first
amendment
but what are future judges going to be
like
they're they're the product of this
academy as well and during the brett
kavanaugh hearings you had
students from the harvard and yale law
schools
protesting saying believe survivors you
know
trying to torpedo uh the kavanaugh
nomination
the belief survivors mantra that is the
absolute central
plank of feminism today is completely
antithetical to
due process it is the rejection of the
presumption of innocence
the hate speech conceit that we're
seeing now
weaponized in the world at large to do
censorship when you have
members of the press saying we should
censor fox news we should de-platform
everybody
because hate speeches behavior speech
destroys people's lives as you pointed
out hate speech is not a
constitutionally protected
or you know recognized category the
judges
the judges that we are entrusting with
our constitution
are the products of the academy that is
giving us these
these poisonous ideas so i don't know
how much longer
we can count on america the way we know
it
to have been it's so i mean it's it's
scary what you're saying there but i
think
what i hear from a lot of conservatives
is oh the courts are the sort of last
line on this that maybe trump got enough
judges in
for now because he did get a lot of i
mean with something like 400 judges if
i'm not mistaken he got a ton of judges
in
that that's the last line but but i
think you're right it's also that
they're a function of the culture and
everything else and the more we target
individual people and then they get
scared and they don't want to be called
a racist
on top of the fact that they themselves
may have been indoctrinated
at at some level it's uh it's a scary
stew
uh let let me shift to something that
you might find a little more uh
inspiring then i was at uh the turning
point usa student action summit uh right
before christmas
and uh we've talked about this before
but you're you're a non-religious
conservative which sometimes people find
to be an oxymoron i do not and we've had
a couple interesting chats about it
but at turning point they had a
conservative secular
coalition there it was the first time
this group had been invited
and there was there were a lot of them
there i did an interview with them
and as i was talking i think i brought
you up in the interview but i see
something really nice
happening there that there suddenly is
this sort of burst
of secular conservatism uh and i thought
you might just like to hear that
interesting no i was unaware of that
that's fantastic it doesn't necessarily
change a lot of the other rhetoric that
comes out of
a lot of conservative talk show hosts
but but
you know again if we if we really
believe in being inclusive
uh that's that's a good thing yeah that
seemed to be the overriding idea so sort
of going back a little bit to the
to the censorship part of this has any
of the big tech censorship the way
they're trying to kick fox off the air
their way the way they're trying to get
rid of youtubers or saying that you
can't talk about any of these things
has any of that pushed your free market
principles
to the breaking point that seems to be a
new place that libertarians and
conservatives
are fighting at the moment like oh we
should have used the power of the
government when we had trump to break up
the
tech monopolies or do you fully believe
in the free market or
some combination thereof
yeah this again is not my expertise
and i'm the the big thing
that i find so astounding with the the
members of the liberal elites that are
calling now from censorship
is their childlike inability to think in
terms of principles
they think that they will always have
power and that therefore they can
establish the precedent of uh
shutting down speech that will never be
used against them
and you think my god you know it an
adult is supposed to be able to abstract
from
his own situation to think in terms
of neutral principles and i used to go
around to college campuses
and and say to the the lefty students
who were yes also
screaming and and you know having heart
attacks at my very presence there say
do you want this power of censorship
in the hands of donald trump and
ironically trump
did not try to censor people but now you
have
you know max boot and washington post
writers and
heads of columbia journalism school
saying well you know this free speech
thing is not really so great we got to
get rid of it
but what if we get trump 2024 god forbid
or somebody else it's going to use it
against you and i would so i would say
the same thing
uh with taking on the the big tech
companies
that they are private and so
i i'm i'm worried about any kind of
precedent that would be used for
government
to go after a private entity because we
may think we're doing it
in a for a good cause now but
the tables can always turn but
this is something that is above my pay
grade i am
i leave it to you to figure out a way
out of
what i do because it is it's damn yeah i
know the tech part isn't necessarily
your area of expertise but i knew you
could give me a sort of philosophical
underpinning there but all right so
going back to a little bit more
of of where you focus um we have heard
joe biden
say the phrase equity roughly 1 billion
times in his few weeks of i'll have to
get fact checked on that
but in his few weeks of office i mean
equity equity equity
you may remember that just what two or
three days before the election
kamala harris released that video on
twitter talking about that we should all
end up in the same place this is
obviously very different than equality
are you kind of shocked or does it just
all fit that that
we sort of slipped equity under the
guise of equality into the system just
that quickly where now if you say you're
against equity
which is just sort of an imaginary
position
uh well of course you're racist and
everything else
yeah well equity uh
is another it's a synonym for
the sort of the obverse which is racism
and white supremacy i've been hearing
more my ears more attuned to biden's
endless repetition of systemic racism
and uh they're the same thing
i mean equity is the response to
systemic racism
equity means quotas
it means the destruction of meritocratic
standards it means
you hire and promote on the basis of
race not on the basis of qualifications
and any institution which does not show
a proportional number
uh of of blacks or hispanics
is thereby by definition uh
systemically racist and engaged in bias
and and i'm fully expecting ibrahim
kendy
the big anti-racist uh uh huckster right
now who's probably the most highest paid
of them he may have even
bumped out tonight coates to end up in
the federal government and set up a
agency of anti-racism that will go after
every private institutions using the
re the completely dangerous and
unjustified tool of disparate impact
which holds that any neutral process
such as saying
we expect you as a uh alzheimer's
researcher
to have a highly competitive knowledge
of the way neurology works
if that standard has a disparate impact
on blacks
then you get rid of the standard and say
we're going to replace it with quotas
the fact of the matter is
the academic skills gap in this country
is so vast that it is preposterous
to claim that the lack of proportional
representation
in any institution is the result of bias
the facts are these black 8th graders
54 of all black 8th graders in this
country
do not even have basic math skills
basic is defined by the national
association
of of educational progress the naep
as partial mastery of math concepts
54 of black eighth graders
are below basic in their math skills
forty percent are below basic
in their reading skills that is they do
not even have partial mastery
of eighth grade reading skills that gap
does not close
it continues at the sat level where you
have a standard deviation of gap
lsats gmats mcats
everywhere you see that discussion by
the way their response is
to now get rid of many of these things
right right exactly
they're going to get rid of that's why
they're getting rid of
the l the sats and
my prediction is we are also eventually
going to get rid of crime data
you are going to have police departments
it's already
very hard uh to get your hands
on crime offending data and
and criminal victimization data as well
and that is eventually going to be
repressed as well
in order to further strengthen the phony
narrative
that the disproportion of blacks in the
prison system
is due to racism not to exponentially
higher rates of criminal offending
so i think when some people hear
you say that when they hear okay well 54
of black eighth graders aren't at at
that level
or the level that they should be at that
they say well then that proves that
their systemic racism if
if it's so disproportionate to black
people i think at a surface level
thought
i think that's what happens there so can
you just can you just go a little bit
beneath that
maybe in as a comparison to the asian
community because i know you've written
a lot about that
well i've proposed a thought experiment
which is that
if blacks acted like asians for 10 years
with all
in all regards to things with that have
a bearing on
academic success on success in life
such as being fanatical about
school work you know having parents that
care about whether you're
going to class whether you're truant or
not
taking your textbooks home studying for
the next exam
not you know screaming at your teacher
beating up your teacher
not getting involved in drugs or gangs
having a very low out of wedlock birth
rate
if if all those behaviors were the same
and then we saw the socio-economic
disparities
that we do then it would be
more than enough time to start talking
about systemic racism
but right now you have a culture
and and you have addressed this dave
with your fantastic interview with
brandon of blexit
uh a inner city culture that
stigmatizes academic effort that
celebrates violence criminality
uh that is completely inimical to
success in life
when the behaviors are so different it
is way
premature to talk about systemic racism
there is a lot that can be done
at least in theory i mean we've been
trying for decades without a whole lot
of success
but it remains theoretically possible
to change the culture and the behaviors
that i think are
clearly related to the fact that we
don't have
absolute equity in outcomes that
that kamala harris and biden pretend
to want and as long as we can know can't
talk about those behaviors
and we keep going down this path of
demanding more quotas
more transfer payments nothing is going
to change yeah and by the way of course
the great thomas soul who's been talking
about this forever that that in effect
is what the welfare state did
do you think there's anything though the
government could do
let's say we had a government certainly
not the government we have at the
federal level now but if there was a
government to come in
and say okay we want to address these
issues around the family around
generations on welfare all of these
things we want to address it
what do you do i mean i've heard some
people like candace owen say you just
you just stop the programs tomorrow and
you let that pain point hit
do you think there's a sensible policy
there do you say just end everything
what's the what's the actual action that
can happen
government cannot do social uplift it
doesn't know how to do it
and of course right now you have
government you know the social school
social work schools are cranking out
government workers that are utterly
committed
to non-judgmentalism when it comes to
self-destructive behavior like
i i remember in the six in the 90s in
new york i used to
write a lot about welfare reform and
would talk to these
non-profit workers and they were adamant
that they couldn't say
a word about out of wedlock childbearing
which is the biggest predictor of
poverty in this country
if if we could wipe out out of wedlock
child rearing
re-knit families together we'd get rid
of poverty and we'd get rid of
almost all crime and it's it's happening
now in the white community as well among
you know the the hillbilly elegy
population as well charles has written
about that
uh so government does not know how to
change people's upbringing so
yes it would be a great thing i would
absolutely back candace owens of going
cold turkey and there were proposals
uh about that for uh during the welfare
reform era
of the 1990s of at least not giving more
checks larger checks when people had
more children out of wedlock
but that was a very hard sell i would
say government
you know what it's there for is
providing public order providing
the basis for people to exercise their
own initiative
that is above all safe streets so that
businesses don't have to worry about
their employees they can set up shop
uh and and people can thrive and get
where they need to go without fear
you're speaking my language it's so
interesting what you said about in the
90s and the social workers and they
couldn't bring up the you know the one
parent household it reminds me of
something that david horowitz who i'm
sure you know have told me once when he
was still a lefty
in new york city politics in the early
80s during the aids crisis
um they or he was just sort of
becoming a republican in essence and
they knew that the aids crisis that in
effect ground zero
was these gay bath houses because people
were having all kinds of sex and doing
drugs and all sorts of stuff
and the republicans wanted to close down
the bath houses but the democrats said
no you're a bunch of homophobes
and you hate gay people thus they
actually extended the crisis probably
for
for years and years after that because
it's just this it's the same culture of
fear
in essence well i've said
the big divide between conservatives
and liberals or progressives or leftists
is
whether you see behavior as
the most important determinant of life
outcomes
or you see large systemic structures as
the determinant and
i'm sure there's you know counter
examples here but by and large
uh a liberal is going to say but look
you know there's these huge structures
uh homophobia or racism
that prevent people from thriving
and and again in the case of aids i mean
it was just remarkable
that we were not allowed to talk about
uh
grotesquely promiscuous sex and and
we're
pretending that aids is like an airborne
disease
an infectious disease as opposed to
something that is
almost a hundred percent avoidable by
not doing intravenous drugs
uh and not engaging in anonymous sex
uh with people who you have no idea
what their std status is or anything you
can avoid it 100
and but and so a conservative is going
to
focus on those behavioral choices that
people make
uh and be more skeptical and a liberal
would say
how can you be so blind to the systemic
structural barriers
and and that's it's again it's one of
those constitutional divides
in how we look at the world that is very
hard to
to bridge do you think the the more and
more you do these things that you study
these things talk about these things and
the more we've seen
so much of of what you talk about come
true
do you ultimately think that it's partly
just the way our brains are wired
at the end that it's just some people's
fear center
is this and some people's other fear
center is that so the mask then
for some people you walk around and go
oh man these people are bananas that's
sort of where i'm at
but then someone else thinks it actually
in some way is giving them purpose
in in a bizarre sense that's absolutely
right
it it does give you purpose and you feel
like you're part of something bigger and
and fear is is as i say it gives you
feel like you're alive and it also gives
you
virtue yeah i do and and i also think
we're all susceptible to enormous
cognitive
blindnesses you know i and uh
so i'm sure you know conservatives are
are just as
inconsistent in their application of
principles i mean we've all seen the
the sort of seesaw go up and down as to
whether one's in favor of executive
orders based on
whether your guy's in office or not so i
do kind of despair
i mean i i have to say uh and
and this is going to anger a lot of
people and alienate a lot of people
but i have been uh
depressed by seeing the willingness of
so many
people on the on the right to embrace
what i think are just completely
ridiculous conspiracy theories with
regards to
dominion voting systems and to not
apply the hume test this the
test for miracles of having a basic
skepticism
towards claims which asks is it more
likely than not is it more likely than
not
uh that there was a systemic uh
conspiracy across all levels of
government in this country
to destroy trump votes to me that is
it's it just it's a step too far but
people have selective rationality
uh and so i think that kind of a
libertarian
view that views everybody is it's all
going to come out all right in the wash
because
we're all rational it's not quite the
way it works and we've had people like
daniel kahneman for
years now point out the the
the the sort of uh failures of how
human beings are wired cognitively and
our
uh uh tendency towards the agency where
it doesn't exist
i would say that's part of the religious
impulse as well
so one can only hope and make those
arguments
as as often as one can from one's own
perspective of rationality
knowing that we are i am fallible too
and
and i think we need some epistemological
humility
uh towards our own positions as as
as even as we're criticizing what appear
to be
complete insanity on the side of our
ideological opponents that probably
is the right place to stop because it
was a beautiful ending but i'm gonna
push you one further which is that my
my audience knows that i'm really trying
to help people just not feel crazy about
all of this because the world
really does feel crazy we're we're
watching the close of the old world
we're watching the beginning of a new
world that feel that is going to feel
very different no matter what
um i sense you're probably
similar to the way i think of myself i
consider myself a world-weary
optimist but but really a realist more
than anything else i i think you
probably
you certainly must consider yourself a
realist but can you can you track
some sort of future that looks okay over
the next couple years
like is there something that you can
sort of see in the distance that's like
oh we can get through this
without the complete destruction of
everything that
you know is good
the truth i mean i i just and i'm not
a world very optimist i'm a world very
pessimistic again this is a
constitutional difference
i can tell i'm not an optimist by nature
and i know that clouds how i see things
and i'm
i find optimus crazy like how can you
guys think it's going to get better
it's not but let's pretend but no there
are there are ways the only way out of
this
is the truth do not be cowed by the
charge of racism
i do believe that the core problem in
all of our world today
is the uh racial gap and the idea that
america is racist
white supremacist that's driving an
enormous
portion of the current insanity we have
to speak the truth
about accomplishment about culture
and and not allow our history and our
civilization to be torn down
based on hatred resentment uh
and and mediocrity stick up for what you
love i'm gonna stick up for the the art
that i think is
is greater than any of us have any right
to us to desert we do not deserve the
beauty
of chopin and brahms piano music and
mozart operas
none of us have done anything to justify
this cornucopia
of sublimity keep fighting for it
keep fighting for what you believe with
respect not violence
uh but that's all you can do is just go
down fighting at the very least
heather mcdonald you are truly one of my
favorite guests your most recent book is
the diversity delusion which we'll link
to
right down below and uh you're you're in
oc i'm here in l.a
maybe we meet in the middle for coffee i
don't want to get arrested we'll see
what happens
we'll wear a mask two minutes thank you
so much heather
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell